lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre la noción del marco de
referencia
este es un vídeo introductorio en
futuros vídeos veremos esto con mayor
detalle pero el marco de referencia
realmente es la idea de un punto de
vista desde donde medir las cosas y
verán que muchas de las cantidades que
medimos en física como la velocidad o el
desplazamiento podrían ser diferentes
dependiendo del punto de vista o del
marco de referencia desde donde estamos
tomando las medidas y para poder tener
una intuición de esto he dibujado aquí
tres escenarios iguales para tres marcos
de referencia diferentes en el primer
marco de referencia tomaremos el punto
de vista del suelo haremos nuestras
medidas tomando como referencia el suelo
si somos un observador estacionario en
el suelo aquí estamos y somos los
encargados de tomar las mediciones
digamos que queremos medir la velocidad
desde nuestro punto de vista ya que
estamos estacionarios en el suelo
como luce la velocidad del suelo pues si
estamos parados en el suelo este va a
aparecer estacionario nos va a parecer
que no se mueve y para medir la
velocidad vamos a ver cuál es el
desplazamiento en el tiempo tanto del
avión como del auto y podemos decir que
este avión se mueve a la derecha a 250
metros por segundo y digamos que este
auto se está moviendo se está moviendo
bastante rápido para hacer un auto y se
mueve hacia la izquierda a 50 metros por
segundo esto no es para nada extraño
podríamos salir a la calle y observar la
velocidad a la que se mueven los autos y
podríamos ver que ocurren cosas
parecidas a las de este escenario pero
qué pasa si cambiamos nuestro marco de
referencia nuestro punto de vista el
punto de vista desde el que hacemos
nuestras mediciones tomemos el punto de
referencia del auto supongamos que ahora
nos encontramos adentro de este auto
quizá no lo vamos conduciendo porque
vamos a hacer mediciones quizás este
vehículo es autónomo
aquí tenemos nuestros instrumentos de
medición
y podemos ver cuál es el desplazamiento
del suelo o del avión durante digamos un
segundo y en este caso desde nuestro
punto de vista el auto está estacionario
y desde nuestro punto de vista podremos
medir la velocidad a la que se está
moviendo el suelo podemos observar que
los árboles se mueven hacia atrás así
que desde nuestro punto de vista el
suelo da la impresión de moverse en esta
dirección a 50 metros por segundo dará
la impresión de que en este caso se está
moviendo hacia la derecha y ahora cuánto
medirá el desplazamiento del avión bueno
no sólo parecerá que se mueve a la
derecha a 250 metros por segundo pero en
relación con nosotros dará la impresión
de que se mueve aún más rápido porque
nosotros estamos yendo hacia la
izquierda si lo vemos desde el punto de
vista del suelo estacionario a 50 metros
por segundo así que para nosotros desde
el auto nos va a parecer que el avión se
mueve hacia la derecha a 250 más
los 50 metros de nuestro desplazamiento
hacia la derecha con un total de 300
metros por segundo
y ahora qué pasará si nuestro marco de
referencia es el del avión pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar cuáles serán
las velocidades del avión el auto y el
suelo desde el punto de vista del avión
hagamos esto juntos ahora nos
encontramos adentro del avión
nosotros no vamos manejando el avión a
alguien más lo hace así que nosotros
desde aquí tomamos nuestros instrumentos
para medir el desplazamiento en el
tiempo del auto y del suelo ya que
estamos adentro del avión este nos va a
parecer estacionario lo que podría
parecernos poco intuitivo pero si alguna
vez se han subido a un avión y han
viajado sin turbulencia o a lo mejor con
todas las ventanas cerradas y el avión
no está despegando y aterrizando muchas
veces si cerramos los ojos no nos damos
cuenta de que nos estamos moviendo desde
el punto de vista de nosotros viajando
adentro del avión nos va a parecer que
el avión está estacionario sin embargo
el suelo va a parecer que se mueve muy
rápidamente parece que se mueve hacia
atrás a una velocidad de 250 metros por
segundo a 250 metros por segundo a la
izquierda y el auto se va a mover hacia
la izquierda aún más
se va a mover 50 metros por segundo más
rápido que el suelo hacia la izquierda
así que veremos que se mueve hacia la
izquierda un total de 300 metros por
segundo con esto podemos apreciar que
son los marcos de referencia es el punto
de vista desde el cual tomamos nuestras
mediciones y quizá muchos de ustedes les
parezca que debe haber un punto de
referencia que sea el correcto para
nuestro mundo cotidiano quizá podríamos
decir que este es el marco de referencia
correcto y estos otros dos simplemente
los imaginamos o son un error y esto nos
parece así porque tomamos como marco de
referencia este objeto enorme que es el
planeta tierra pero resulta que ninguno
de estos marcos de referencia es más
válido que los demás todos son marcos de
referencia válidos no quiere decir que
sean equivalentes ya que en cada uno
obtuvimos mediciones diferentes pero
desde el punto de vista de la física
todos son marcos de referencia válidos